first of all congrats on your at first
Golden Globe and the BAFTA nomination
and I saw an interview where you
mentioned that August Wilson told your
dad's story how so and how personal for
you was this particular role well he
told the story of the average black man
he saw the value in that story you know
Arthur Miller you know said when he
wrote really low men that I know that
these are not the finest men who ever
lived but a terrible thing has happened
to them so their stories deserve to be
told um and these are not the men who
are changing history but they have the
story and their stories through hearing
those stories those are the stories The
Chronicle where we were as
african-americans it's those thousands
millions of the average black person who
maybe wasn't educated maybe didn't know
how to read my father didn't know how to
read till he was 15 um those are the
stories that let you know where we were
how they affected our relationships and
sometimes I think we missed that with
biopic we missed that those little
details of relationships and the
everyday and I'm glad that he saw value
in it I'm glad august wilson saw value
in it how much is that the role and the
whole setting about racism i mean could
you have played this role from any
ethnicity do you think the other themes
that are pertinent to all people there's
a lot of things that you could have
played it does matter the ethnicity
marriage the downfall of a marriage
someone feeling stagnant and saying I
need someone younger cuter more vibrant
I'm gonna leave my own wife I'm
impregnating another woman and I want
you to raise this child I think that
that very much is prevalent nowadays and
not just exclusive to the
african-american experience I think the
dynamic between father son
is our friend friend with Bono and Troy
um i think is very inclusive I think
that's what happens when you write the
human story instead of approaching it in
a way that's didactic where each
character is just a social message and
that's it it that's all it is that's not
what what August wrote and I looked at
the role and really empathize with it
from start to finish but at the point
where you decided to raise your
husband's love child that's where I
ended affiliation thought I could never
do that I mean as a woman as a married
woman is that something that you could
identify with I mean could you do that
raise another woman's child number one I
did not I did not see that moment as
whether or not I could identify it um at
it having value it doesn't matter um but
number two I saw it is admirable I saw
it as being on the page so me having to
play it um number three I think that
that is something that a lot of women do
I know him personally they're in my life
you know I know someone in my life was
raising her husband's child because he
had an affair with the woman who can't
raise a kid she would be left alone and
so she's raising that child with a love
I don't see that as a weakness I see it
is very admirable I see Rose is making a
difference in that child's life um I
have a different definition of being
what strong is at 51 i do i always
thought strong was i'm doing what i want
to do how I want to do it and the way I
want to do it and then now I'm woken up
to the fact that that's all a lie
I mean I have friends who say that and
there with men who beat them I have
friends who say that and they're
alcoholics I've set friends who say that
and there you know popping
antidepressants and they're busy
drinking because they're completely
stressed out or they're in therapy three
or four times a week because they just
can't cope um we as human beings I not
without flaws and I and I love the fact
that August created a character who
absolutely is strong at times but
absolutely is vulnerable and absolutely
is doing the best she can with what she
knew I mean you talk about human beings
not being without floors that one of
those powerful scenes is when you're
told about this love child and you're
crying and you know you your nose is
running and you know everything is on
display for you certainly in that moment
it wasn't about vanity was it it can't
be about penalty you know the you know
how they describe acting they describe
acting is being naked in front of an
audience and turning around very slowly
acting is about exposing and thank God
for artists because I probably have
moved through life and maybe ninety
percent of the people i know especially
on facebook they're the most fabulous
mother they are the most in control i
have one woman who I know and I love her
by the way and she always is posting how
fabulous and in control she is and I
know for a fact he's got marriage is
falling apart she'll sexuality issue she
has but that's most people that I know
there are agoraphobic they're alcoholics
they're all of that that the biggest
issue with people is the complete lack
of self-awareness that they have
and it's why most of us are medicated
your job as an actor is not to do that
because most of the time when you are
acting like you see in fences you are
coming into someone's house and seeing
them in private and you're seeing them
when they are taking off the masks when
they're not putting on that armor of
having to show you the best parts of
themselves and what happens when you
expose as author Miller said after
Miller said he wrote death of a salesman
view from the bridge all of those plays
because he wants people to feel less
alone people feel less alone when they
exposed their vulnerability because then
the person who is observing it can go oh
me too thank God because I never want to
show that me goes off I want people know
I'm together that's the beauty of august
wilson also let's talk about diversity
huge well the Oscars last year about
diversity of actors in films and films
nomination do you think that we've come
over that now do you think that the
Oscars are moving in the the right
direction and Hollywood's moving in the
right direction um yeah because I well I
think it's it is moving in the right
direction it's directing because i think
that people of color are refusing to put
hollywood in the driver's seat they are
being the instrument of change but i
always say my three biggest words or the
question mark at the end and now what
oscars are going to be over februari 26
and now what what kind of films are
being good are going to be produced what
are the storylines I'm one of those
people that I feel that stories are
expansive I want stories that are
completely imaginative I don't always
want to be the together black woman who
only puts out images
cuz look great that's horrible art as a
matter of fact if you just do that
that's going to be bad movie making and
nobody's going to get an Oscar based on
that people get Oscars when you write
stories about great ideas where human
beings are messy and in conflict and if
you we can write that with this color
then you can come back with me with that
question and I'll say that we're at the
sweet spot but if it's just by optics
all the time we're just beautiful I hair
is straight skin is beautiful my skin
looks great because being lit right then
that's not a story as far as I'm
concerned I'm praying that we keeps
churning out movies that are diverse
stories or expansive stories or
imaginative we have people of different
hues it's not just all black I think
that we can mix it up the other Davis
thank you very much screen begin thank
you